to the Clinton campaign now and another
release of hacked emails the batch that
was just released continues to raise
questions about what Democratic
presidential nominee says in public and
then what she says in private Nancy
Cordes takes a look America is better
than this in Seattle Clinton said Trump
has become an international
embarrassment I take no satisfaction and
seeing what Trump does and says because
it hurts it hurts me and it hurts our
country but Clinton might want to thank
her opponent who's wildly obscured the
wikileaks release of more than 10,000
emails hacked from the account of her
campaign chair John Podesta they reveal
he got a barrage of free advice from
outside allies about how Clinton could
shore up nagging shortcomings former
michigan governor jennifer Granholm
suggested last July that Clinton combat
the image that she is out of touch or in
a bubble by selecting eight occupations
that she is willing to spend one day
working at for example perhaps she buses
tables at denny's or works behind the
counter at McDonald's last september's
Podesta's former think-tank partner near
a Tandon wrote everyone wants her to
apologize over her use of a private
server and she should apologies are like
her Achilles heel in January Democratic
strategist Steve Hildebrand advised she
needs to find an emotional connection
she also needs to be bold and not be
politically calculating the messages go
back 10 years in one from 2008 a group
of Democratic strategists prepare a
public survey to test attacks against
then-senator Barack Obama including his
father was a Muslim his former use of
cocaine and his support of issues like
gay adoption strategist Paul Begala who
was part of that email exchange says the
survey was not put together for the 08
Clinton campaign he says it was an
effort to test the potency of potential
attacks by Republican John McCain if mr.
Obama became the Democratic nominee
Nancy Cortes CBS News wash